[Musica]
1988 siamo in America è un gruppo di
insegnanti di scuole elementari
protestano stanno protestando per
l'abuso di della calcolatrice
all'interno appunto delle scuole Qual è
il loro timore Qual è la loro paura e
che i loro piccoli studenti
dimentichino Come si facciano i calcoli
sappiamo poi dopo verso 2007-2008
ricerche sempre americane hanno
attestato come l'utilizzo di quello
strumento la calcolatrice di quella
tecnologia in realtà non ha nessun
aspetto negativo sull'apprendimento anzi
i bambini che hanno saputo dialogare con
quello strumento hanno riuscito a
risolvere più problemi sono hanno
velocizzato le loro utilizzo durante il
mondo scolastico
Ma che cos'è l'intelligenza artificiale
oggi vi parlo proprio di questo e ho
provato a chiederlo attraverso un prompt
testuale un comando Con quale attraverso
del testo si può chiedere diverse cose
e ce la fa Eh anche la i ce la faccio
mette un po' Ma poi arriva all'output
e l'output e
inquietante quanto affascinante
l'intelligenza artificiale si descrive
attraverso un cervello umano se notate
molto bene all'interno di questo
cervello ci sono altri piccoli cervelli
colorati tutti colorati che creano una
connessione di dati e di scelte
l'intelligenza artificiale si descrive
come una macchina che riesce a imitare
il comportamento umano in modo veloce e
in modo performante
possiamo riassumere l'intelligenza
artificiale Con un'unica parola
tecnologia
sono nato negli anni Ottanta e quando ho
iniziato a unire creatività strategia e
tecnologia o esplorato anch'io il mondo
dell'intelligenza artificiale e la
cultura Popolare ci porta a vedere un
intelligenza artificiale sfuggita di
mano dall'umanità e la rivediamo in
saggistica in serie tv in film molto
spesso sotto forma di robot Non so
perché ma sono delle macchine terribili
che uccidono poi alla fine tutti e
questo genera paura genera timore
ma riflettiamo insieme Seguitemi se vi
parlo di energia nucleare
la parola nucleare ci spaventa perché
sappiamo che quella parola lì ha uno
storico progetto Manhattan bomba
nucleare una tecnologia
meravigliosa in termini matematici
fisici ma abbiamo visto come l'essere
umano non è riuscito ad imbrigliare
questa tecnologia Anzi ha danneggiato
noi stessi ha creato una cicatrice nella
nostra storia
Ma
se ci fosse una nuova linea temporale in
cui alla parola nucleare fosse collegata
energia pulita per tutti energia Green
per tutto il pianeta molto probabilmente
non avremo più timore non avremo più
paura perché Perché non è la tecnologia
che deve far paura Ma probabilmente il
come utilizzeremo questa tecnologia
paura la paura è una delle emozioni da
sempre presenti nel nel genere umano e
anche nel regno animale e una emozione
che ci serve per sopravvivenza ci fa
capire quando c'è un pericolo pensate
preziosissima nei primi anni di vita
e quindi non dobbiamo declinare aver
paura La paura fa parte di noi ed è
corretto ad averla
arrivo da una famiglia gentile che mi ha
insegnato a comprendere e a condividere
le emozioni Alcune ci sto ancora
lavorando È difficile le emozioni creano
connessioni le emozioni definiscono chi
siamo come ci relazioniamo
e oggi vorrei portarvi tutti con me nel
in questo mio Talk e vorrei provarvi a
coinvolgere in una connessione Vi chiedo
gentilmente di alzarvi tutti in piedi
e di fare una cosa semplice
di abbracciare la persona che al vostro
fianco per qualche secondo decidete chi
potete fare anche abbracci di gruppo
sentitelo quell'abbraccio
Ok state iniziando a sentirlo
vi sente bellissimo è bellissimo questa
cosa
avete potete sedervi Avete appena
provato una connessione molto unica una
connessione che oggi
ci contraddistingue dalla macchina la
macchina o modelli di intelligenza
artificiale oggi riescono ad imitare un
tono di voce un trattamento ma non
riesce a ricevere e a dare emozioni
quello Ad oggi ancora legato a noi al
genere umano
ma
l'intelligenza artificiale è un
acceleratore un acceleratore comunque di
connessioni di
velocizzare alcune operazioni
lui è Vincenzo mio papà nel 2009
purtroppo ci ha lasciati per uno dei
grandi Mali che spesso si sente e ci ha
lasciato in una notte in modo gentile
come era lui e fatemi dire io ho un
grande sogno che questo non accada più
e forse
questo sogno non è così lontano
I ricercatori del MIT hanno creato un
sistema con intelligenza artificiale che
addestrato con diverse cartelle cliniche
è riuscito a prevedere sei mesi prima la
formazione di un tumore tumore al seno
e meraviglioso questa cosa è fantastico
e questo il come ci piace il come questa
tecnologia può essere applicata al
genere umano
Ma dove ci troviamo ora ci troviamo
nella cosiddetta era della distribuzione
dell'intelligenza artificiale
ci troviamo in un momento nel quale ogni
singolo individuo ha la possibilità di
utilizzare alcuni strumenti per
velocizzare alcune operazioni lo stiamo
vedendo nel mondo creativo nel mondo
marketing diversi strumenti molto
semplici da utilizzare che sono usciti
dal mondo accademico dal mondo della
ricerca e sono andati alla massa e
questo ci permetterà tutti noi oggi di
velocizzare di avere un Boost rispetto a
tutti gli altri
stiamo vivendo il cosiddetto iPhone
Moment una rivoluzione culturale
tecnologica una rivoluzione che creerà
nuovi posti di lavoro creerà nuove
necessità nuovi scenari tutti da
scoprire
e quando penso a questa nuova
rivoluzione non posso non pensare alle
nuove generazioni e quindi penso
ai vostri figli Penso a mio figlio
Leonardo a 5 anni ed è una furia
pazzesca non si ferma mai è molto
probabilmente sarà anche lui coinvolto
in tutta questa rivoluzione in modo
diretto e indiretto magari ci saranno
delle prime professionalità che lui
sceglierà e la i farà parte di questa di
questo suo di questo suo lavoro
E sì ci aspetta un futuro Davvero
magnifico a livello tecnologico ma allo
stesso tempo una sfida immensa
una sfida etica avremo saremo custodi di
questa costruzione di questa costruzione
di questa tecnologia in modo etico
Dovremmo lavorare in modo responsabile
anche a livello
culturale
senza ledere diritti civili senza ledere
religioni o altre culture
privacy una grandissima sfida
l'intelligenza artificiale questi
modelli si cibano di dati dei nostri
dati e quindi dovremmo trovare un modo
per regolamentare questo utilizzo di
dati nessuno vuole diventare nuovamente
il prodotto di altre aziende che in
questo caso lavorano con l'intelligenza
artificiale
e infine un aspetto legale questi
contenuti soprattutto nel mondo creativo
hanno una paternità ci sono degli
artisti dei fotografi da cui
l'intelligenza artificiale prende queste
informazioni per crearne dei nuovi Ma
dobbiamo tutelare anche loro con codici
etici con regolamentazioni europee
Insomma ci aspetta un futuro
meraviglioso a livello tecnologico a
livello di innovazioni Io sono
contentissimo ma allo stesso tempo
questa sfida dobbiamo affrontarla
dobbiamo abbracciarla senza aver paura
lo dobbiamo fare in primis noi per la
nostra generazione ma soprattutto per
quella che verrà la nuova generazione
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]